meine damen und herren bitte nehmen sie
wieder ihre plätze ein wir machen weiter
wie sie sehen haben wir unseren nächsten
gast bereits zugeschaltet auf dem
bildschirm
es ist mehr ein privileg und eine freude
unseren nächsten redner vorzustellen
staatsrat und außenminister chinas
in den letzten jahren
haben wir immer die dialog linien offen
gehalten und das war uns hier bei der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz
jemand eine priorität selbst sobald die
usa
und europa vielleicht eine kritische
einstellung zu china und ihren
beziehungen zu china eingenommen haben
heute kann ich nur unterstreichen da
sind wir
absolut entschlossen sind weiter in
münchen
beziehungen zu führen mit china und
gespräche zu führen nicht nur über china
sondern mit china und ich wäre sehr froh
wenn ich das gleich über
unseren nachbarn im osten russland
im jahr 2020 als letztes mal für sich
persönlich hier in diesem raum war
schon mit dem beginn der u 19 pandemie
zu tun die damals begann die
internationalen schlagzeilen zu
dominieren
leider muss ich sagen haben wir die
pandemie ja immer noch nicht komplett
hinter uns bringen können und daher
erlauben ist die umstände ministerrang
leider nicht persönlich hier zu sein und
natürlich
finden auch derzeit noch die olympischen
spiele in china statt und ich denke das
sicherlich sehr viele internationale
besuchten und besucher nach china kommen
die der minister muss daher ist er heute
virtuell zu gestaltet und ist auch
bereit im rahmen unserer engen zeit
medien auf einige fragen zu antworten
machen sie sich keine sorgen wenn sie
nicht fließend mandarin sprechen sie
können einfach sich die kopfhörer
aufsetzen und der dolmetscher motion
vielen herzlichen dank herr minister
der staatsrat dass sie sich heute die
zeit für uns genommen haben
und sie haben nun das wort bitte schön
vielen dank herr botschafter ischinger
mein alter freund es ist sehr schön sie
wieder einmal zu sehen
es ist mir eine große freude
erneut an der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz um teilzunehmen und
hier alte und neue freunde zu treffen in
den letzten jahren
wurde dieses thema unsicherheit sehr
stark diskutiert und dieses jahr kommt
ein gefühl der hilflosigkeit dazu und
dies zeigt wie verwirrt die länder sind
was den zustand der welt der welt angeht
und auch sorgen um die zukunft dieser
welt der un-generalsekretär antonio
guterres hatte ich oft darauf
hingewiesen dass ist derzeit ein risiko
einer spaltung der welt gibt und
das erwartet wird dass die länder ihren
internationalen verpflichtungen
nachkomme großer verantwortlichkeit und
wir sehen das ebenso wir stehen vor dem
risiko der division und der
konfrontation die mentalität des kalten
krieges kommt wieder auf
und wir sehen unilaterale sanktionen
somit wird der
internationale das internationale recht
untergrabe und antagonismus gestärkt so
werden mauern aufgebaut und das geht
gegen den trend der globalisierung
hier sehen die hegemonie und
norwegen und das darf so nicht
weitergehen denn das bringt uns
historisch nicht voran wie sollten wir
also reagieren nun solidarität und
kooperation sind zentral unter dem
banner des multilateralismus präsident
shipping hat dies schon beim world
economic forum in diesem jahr angesagt
innerhalb oder zum zeitpunkt einer
globalen krise können wir nicht alle in
unseren kleinen booten sitzen wir sitzen
vielmehr alle in einem gemeinsamen
schiff das in die gleiche richtung
steuert nur wenn wir gemeinsam rudern
und die segel hochziehen können wir
vorankommen wir dürfen uns nicht
in streit verlieren
in diesem sinne sind die handlungen und
die rollen der großen länder ganz
besonders wichtig und ich möchte einige
punkte mit in teilen zunächst einmal um
die welt zu verbessern müssen die großen
länder mit gutem beispiel vorangehen
präsident skijumping hat immer wieder
gesagt dass die großen länder sich ihrer
rolle entsprechend verhalten sollten wir
erwarten von allen großen ländern dass
sie mit führungsstärke vorausgehenden
multilateralismus stärken ihre
verpflichtungen einhalten im sinne der
un charta sich behalten und zum frieden
und zur entwicklung in der welt
beitragen china
tut das schon lange wir ergreifen
konkrete maßnahmen um unseren
internationalen verpflichtungen
nachzukommen zb im kampf gegen die
globale pandemie
wir machen war was präsident skijumping
versprochen hat wir haben zum beispiel
als eines der ersten länder
anderen ländern impfungen zur verfügung
gestellt mittlerweile mehr als 2,1
milliarden
impfdosen an verschiedene länder und
multi
[Musik]
nationale organisationen beispielsweise
nach afrika
die
weltwirtschaft erholt sich langsam und
wir handeln jetzt im sinne der
gemeinsamen entwicklung aller zb durch
die neue seidenstraße welt in droht
initiativ wir konzentrieren uns auf
nachhaltigen
fortschritt mit den menschen im blick
wir haben die 22 30 agenda für
nachhaltige entwicklung hier müssen wir
mit den folgen von co wird 19 folgen
umgehen und wir rufen alle länder auf
zusammen zu handeln und diese agenda
noch einmal neu zu erneuern und
bestärken wir stehen vor komplexen
herausforderungen und haben eine aktive
rolle eingenommen in der stärkung neuer
systeme zu gesundheit digitalisierung
und klima und wir wollen die
globalisierung offener und besser für
alle gestalten
china unterstützt das internationale
system innerhalb der vereinten nationen
und die internationale ordnung auf
grundlage des völkerrechtes wir stehen
vor einer veränderten weltordnung und
wir unterstützen gemeinsam umfassende
und nachhaltige sicherheit und arbeiten
an einer politischen beilegung
regionaler feindseligkeiten wir nehmen
hier an dem ihr konstruktive rolle für
internationalen frieden und sicherheit
ein die fakten zeigen dass die
entwicklung chinas die sicherheit in der
welt verbessert haben und somit auch den
fliegen wir arbeiten hin auf bessere
entwicklung und somit machen wir es
möglich dass wir uns auch über kuwait
hinaus noch besser
entwickeln und frieden und stabilität
fördern um die welt zu einem besseren
ort zu machen zu müssen die länder
gemeinsam arbeiteten wir müssen
gemeinsam arbeiten an einer neuer art
von internationalen
beziehungen basierend auf zusammenarbeit
die beziehung zwischen den ländern
sollten nicht nur sich durch
wettbewerber auszeichnen und kein land
sollte versuchen das rad der geschichte
zurückzudrehen und lallte wähler zu
wiederholen müssen vielmehr hand in hand
arbeiten um
multilateralismus durchzusetzen und die
autorität der vereinten nationen steht
und die prinzipien der un kader müssen
aufrechterhalten werde kein land nicht
einmal eine supermacht sollte die
internationalen normen ersetzen durch
seinen eigenen wellen oder sich über das
völkerrecht stellen es ist wichtig
zusammenzuarbeiten um eine gute der
weltwirtschaft garantieren zu können was
wir ganz besonders brauchen ist
offenheit und integration nicht
entkopplung und isolation titel sich
dicht handelsbarrieren zu entfernen und
offenes und grüne entwicklung zu fördern
und natürlich eine offene weltwirtschaft
in diesem sinne wir sollten wir
zusammenarbeiten für den mit globalen
frieden die sicherheit eines landes
sollte man niemals auf kosten eines
anderes gehen und
nicht vertretbar dass man sich dass ich
militärischen drucks berman es gibt
keine exklusive sicherheit
müssen gegen angriffe
zusammenarbeit gegen einen neuen kalten
legen und für anhaltenden frieden
drittens um die welt offen für diesen
ort zu machen müssen china und europa
ihre jeweiligen
psychose mächte und ruß zivilisationen
von wir müssen und können mehr
stabilität
ihre gemeinsame strategische
partnerschaften weiterführen und sollten
sich nicht von diesem weg abbringen
lassen china werde weiter in die
europäische integration stärken und
unterstützen eine eu mit größeren
größerer
strategischer autonomie ist gleichzeitig
hoffen wir dass
europa sich von dieser partner
wettbewerber rivalen charakterisierung
lösen kann und sich viel mehr öffnen
kann für dialog und zusammenarbeit denn
das würde unseren beiden seiten zusammen
zu bekommen wir können strategische
langfristige beziehungen haben in
hinblick auf eine gesunde und bessere
zukunft fielen die beiden seiten müssen
die jeweiligen interessen respektieren
und sich an internationale normen halten
der nicht einmischung wir haben
unterschiedliche
geschichte aber es ist die mensch und
dementsprechend ist es in diesem ist es
nur verständlich dass wir nicht immer
die gleichen meinung haben aber wir
respektieren einander versuchen einander
zu verstehen und können zusammenarbeiten
träumen und ihren differenzen und
gemeinsam einen weg vorwärts finden die
beiden seiten müssen gemein müssen eine
beziehung entwickeln die für beide
seiten gut ist denn wir haben hier eine
gute
basis wir sollten über die zeit der
pandemie kann auch schauen und unsere
partnerschaft auf eine nächste ebene
heben beispielsweise im bereich des
digitalen denn hier haben wir große
chancen können den aktuellen schwung für
unsere gemeinsamen beziehungen nutzen
die olympischen winterspiele in peking
2022 kommen zu einem ende ich möchte
diese gelegenheit nutzen um nun all den
unterstützern und den teilnehmern an den
spielen zu danken der erfolg dieser
spiele ist sehr groß für china und diese
spiele sehen wirklich die augen der welt
auf china und sie bringen wärme und
hoffnung jetzt in diesen zeiten den
schwierigen zeiten der pandemie und sie
zeigen den wert von frieden und
geschlossenheit und einigkeit gemeinsam
für eine gemeinsame zukunft in das ist
das motto der wikinger winterspiele 2022
und das haben wir schon in der arena
gesehen die selbst die größten
wettbewerber können gegeneinander
antreten und sich gleichzeitig doch
unterstützen denn es geht vor allem
darum besser zu werden und das ist der
geist der uns auch leiten sollte bei den
beziehungen zwischen den staaten in
diesem sinne steht china bereit mit
allen ländern zusammenzuarbeiten denn
wie gesagt wir sitzen alle im gleichen
boot und wenn unser segel sozusagen
unsere gemeinsamkeiten sind dann können
wir durch die pandemie segeln und hinauf
einen schöneren horizont dies
beendet meine ausführungen und ich freue
mich auf den austausch mit ihnen vielen
dank
[Gelächter]
vielen herzlichen dank und wir haben
schon ein paar fragen
wenn sie mir gestatten werde ich mit
einer frage beginnen die mir eingefallen
ist aber ich habe schon mehr oder
weniger dieselbe frage von jazz rock und
von der washington post auf meinen
tablet bekommen gestatten sie mir bitte
die frage vorzulesen
präsident und präsident putin
haben vor zwei wochen sehr viel
aufmerksamkeit auf sich gezogen mit
einer gemeinsamen erklärung und in
dieser gemeinsamen erklärung
setzen sich die beiden seiten
gegen eine weitere erweiterung der nato
natürlich
die nato sich nur erweitern wenn ein
land einen beitritt wunsch äußert wenn
man davon ausgeht dass die nationale
souveränität so wie sie das gerade ja
gesagt haben eines der
schlüsselkriterien chinas ist warum
sollte ein souveränes land dann nicht
die freiheit haben einem bündnis
beizutreten wenn es das möchte
und um die worte zu verwenden die drogen
verwendet hatten das geht nicht gleich
richtungen präsident gesagt
chinas außenpolitik basiert auf nicht
intervention und souveränität warum
äußert sich
china dann nicht klar
gegen die
bedrohung putins der ukraine was ja auch
ein vm mitgliedsland ist
ich denke
ich gehe schon davon aus dass die erste
frage sich auf die ukraine beziehen
würde lassen sie mich noch mal
wiederholen souveränität unabhängigkeit
und territoriale integrität eines jeden
landes sollte geschützt und respektiert
werden denn das ist eine der grund
normen der internationalen beziehungen
das
entspricht auch den
forderungen und den bedingungen der vn
kater und die ukraine macht hier auch
keine ausnahme in dem dokument das die
chinesische regierung veröffentlicht hat
gibt es
erneut die verpflichtung zur sicherheit
gewährleistung und dem schutz der
souveränität und der unabhängigkeit
eines jeden landes und wenn sie diese
position chinas hinterfragen dann ist
das nur sensationalistische und eine
verzerrung der wirklichen chinesischen
position nicht
was die nato am gelangen auch da hat
china eine kontinuierliche
sichtweise und eine klare position der
kalte krieg ist lang vorbei die nato war
ein produkt der zeit des kalten krieges
und jetzt müssen wir uns die gegenwart
betrachten und es muss eine anpassung
der nato geben wenn es eine
kontinuierliche erweiterung nach osten
hin gibt wird das wirklich den frieden
in europa garantieren wird das glücklich
dazu führen dass frieden und stabilität
in europa aufrecht erhalten werden das
ist denke ich eine frage die unsere
freunde in europa sich ernsthaft
überlegen müssen
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt wenn man sich die
situation der ukraine anschauen gibt es
sehr viele gespräche sehr viele
diskussionen
china ist ständiges mitglied des un
sicherheitsrats und wir
sie entscheiden uns immer auf der
grundlage des themas auf der grundlage
der fakten und spielen unsere
konstruktive rolle und was dieses thema
angeht denken wir dass wir zurückkehren
müssen zur ursprünglichen lösung des
minsker abkommens denn dieses abkommen
ist von allen beteiligten parteien
geschlossen worden und das ist ein
bindendes abkommen sicher sie ist
verabschiedet worden wie von vn
sicherheitsrat auch anerkannt worden und
das ist für das ukraine problem die
einzige lösung soweit ich das verstehe
unterstützt die russische seite das neue
minsker abgrund was europa angeht so
unterstützt auch europa dieses abkommen
tony blinken der amerikanische
außenminister hat mich angerufen und hat
wie ich darüber informiert dass auch die
vereinigten staaten dieses abkommen
unterstützen und wenn dies der fall ist
warum können sich nicht alle parteien
zusammensetzen und detaillierte
gespräche führen und eine
zeitachse
erarbeiten einen zeitspanne arbeiten wie
dieses abkommen umgesetzt werden kann
ich denke das ist das was parteien tun
sollten worauf sie sich konzentrieren
sollten
anstatt die spannungen zu verhöhnen
panik zu schüren und vielleicht sogar
noch das risiko eines kriegs zu
sensation ali sieren ich glaube jetzt
sollten alle länder
verantwortung übernehmen und für den
frieden für eine friedliche lösung
eintreten
vielen herzlichen dank
ich habe hier übrigens noch eine meinung
die ich mit ihnen allen teilen möchte
die die ukraine sollte eine brücke sein
die den westen und den osten miteinander
verbindet und sollte keine frontlinie
sein für
einen youtube wettbewerb
zwischen nächten was dieses thema
anbelangt so hat natürlich jede partei
jede seite das recht ihre sorgen zum
ausdruck zu bringen und die sorgen und
bedenken chinas sollten respektiert und
beachtet werden wir hoffen also
dass eine lösung auf der grundlage des
dialogs und der konsultation gefunden
werden kann die dann wirklich sicherheit
und stabilität in europa garantiert und
einen rahmen schaffen kann der eine
lösung erarbeitet und zwar von allen
seiten
vielen herzlichen dank
leider kann ich
mündliche fragen hier aus dem publikum
nicht
aufnehmen sie müssen also über den
chatroom ihre frage stellen wie kann ich
dann vorlesen so funktioniert das aus
technischen gründen haben wir hier
gewisse einschränkungen ich warte also
auf weitere fragen und in der
zwischenzeit
würde ich kenne die folgende frage noch
der herr außenminister
ich bin skilehrer und deswegen ist es
auch ein hobby von mir die winterspiele
zu verfolgen was in den letzten zwei
wochen intensiv getan habe und aufgrund
der beliebtheit der olympischen spiele
ist international china gerade im
rampenlicht so viel aufmerksamkeit geht
nach china weltweit haben viele menschen
jetzt mehr erfahren über das schicksal
der uiguren die situation der arbeit die
arbeitssituation und die
zwangslage in denen diese minderheiten
gruppe sich befinden soll und meine
frage ist also wann wird der
vn hochkommissar für menschenrechte
michael baar schnee
uneingeschränkten zugang zu dieser
region bekommen
solche anschuldigungen zu verifizieren
danke sehr
zuerst einmal lassen sie mich ganz klar
sagen dass in ihm ging es
nie
so genannte systematische zwangsarbeit
oder sogenannte umerziehungslager gab
das sind lügen die
fabriziert und verbreitet wurden als
desinformationen
sie können mir glauben
dass die
chinesische regierung hier die wahrheit
sagt sie können
unseren veröffentlichungen hier trauen
worum geht es hier wirklich nun sink
young ist ein ort der sehr stark
getroffen wurde durch radikale
ideologien und terroristische
extremistische angriffe in der
vergangenheit ist ging von diesen
terroristischen kräften
stark betroffen gewesen die in die
region kamen aus dem ausland um so die
sicherheit dort zu garantieren musste
die lokale regierung handeln um diese
kräfte niederschlagen zu können sie hat
die erfahrung von frankreich und anderen
ländern
aufgegriffen und hat versucht über die
demokratie beschritten die
radikalisierung zu betreiben so das der
nährboden für den extremismus entzogen
werden kann dieser ansatz hat sich
ausgezahlt und er wurde unterstützt und
begrüßt von vertretern aller ethnien in
gang in den vergangenen zwei jahren gab
es keinen einzigen terroristischen
angriff in chan alle bürgerinnen und
bürger auch die schwächeren gruppe
könnten friedlich und glücklich leben
und jin young guitar night und die
gesellschaftliche und wirtschaftliche
entwicklung dort ist gut ist das nicht
auch ein beitrag den china und die
region shin young soo dagegen den
internationalen zum internationalen
kampf gegen terrorismus leistet das ist
doch auch der versuch präventiv gegen
terrorismus vorzugehen
ich denke das sollte vollumfänglich
anerkannt werden nicht nur vom
chinesischen volk sondern auch von der
internationalen gemeinschaft
was die lügen und miss informationen
anbelangt so jin young seine tore
geöffnet gegen yang hat menschen aus
allen teilen der welt eingeladen die
fakten zu überprüfen sich von der von
den tatsachen zu überzeugen vor der
pandemie hat die region shin chan über
2000 menschen unter anderem religiöse
vertreter journalisten und politiker aus
über 100 ländern und internationalen
organisationen eingeladen die selbst
sich davon überzeugen können dass es
frieden wohlstand und stabilität in
xinjiang gibt und dass menschen aller
ethnien dort ihren religiösen glauben
frei nachgehen konnten und können dass
es da etwas in gang an
da wir noch immer in der pandemie leben
gibt es natürlich noch
reiseeinschränkungen und beschränkungen
aber soweit die situation sich
verbessert begrüßen wir alle
interessierten vertreter egal wo sie
herkommen und
ist gerne bereit ein meinungsaustausch
mit
unseren freunden aus dem ausland zu
haben aber um ganz klar zu machen jing
yang möchte keine untersuchung auf der
grundannahme einer schuld wir lehnen
voreingenommene sichtweisen ab und
anklagen die nicht auf tatsachen beruhen
was die
politik chinas anbelangt was dem besuch
von rechnet in china anbelangt nun herr
botschafter
so hat china vor langer zeit schon
willkommen geheißen wir haben gesagt
dass sie gerne china besuchen kann und
während des besuchs auch nach china
einreisen kann es gab noch nie ein
problem in dieser hinsicht das ist ein
ganz normaler austausch zwischen china
und in einer internationalen
organisation
gegenwärtig kommunizieren wir mit
michaela schlett und dem team
und wir hoffen
dass wir hier für ihren besuch ein
eine gute lösung finden natürlich
respektieren wir ihre
wünsche und wir denken wenn sie china
besuchen wird wird sie auch chinas
souveränität
respektieren
sowie die regeln und gesetze
denn so findet ja in der welt ein
normaler austausch statt
wir gehen davon aus dass sie wenn sie
nach china kommt ein china sehen wird
das sich entwickelt und innen jing yang
wird sie eine region kennenlernen die
schließlich und stabil ist in der
menschen in harmonie und glück
zusammenleben tatsachen sind tatsachen
und
davor haben wir die lügen die
desinformation und liedes informationen
werden hier aufgedeckt und werden nicht
bestehen das ist meine antwort auf ihre
frage vielen dank herr vorsitzender
vielen dank
leider haben wir keine zeit mehr ich
denke es hätte sicherlich noch mehr
fragen die geben vielen dank dass sie
sich die zeit genommen haben dieses
thema diese themen hier mit uns zu
besprechen und ich hoffe dass nächstes
jahr hoffentlich nach der pandemie sie
wieder hier mit uns zusammen sein können
in person haben und wir bilaterale
gespräche führen können die für uns alle
von interesse sind und
meines teams und meines nachfolgers
verspreche ich ihnen dass wir weiter mit
ihnen in kontakt bleiben werden und
vielen dank für ihre bereitschaft all
die fragen zu beantworten die unsere
beziehung zu china anbelangt vielen
herzlichen dank herr minister
[Applaus]
botschafter ischinger auch ich möchte
mich bei ihnen bedanken
mir wurde gesagt dass dies ihre letzte
münchner sicherheitskonferenz als
vorsitzender ist ich möchte mich bei
ihnen im namen chinas recht herzlich
bedanken
[Musik]
vielen dank für ihren beitrag zur
aufrechterhaltung des friedens und der
sicherheit in europa und des
gegenseitigen verständnisses zwischen
europa und anderen teilen der welt ich
begrüße auch ihr ziel
ihre faire und inklusive sichtweise und
ich denke sie werden sicherlich noch
weiterhin große beiträge leisten ich
freue mich darauf nächstes jahr wieder
selbst in münchen sein zu können und an
der konferenz teilzunehmen vielen dank
ihn ein
[Applaus]
meine damen und herren bleiben sie bitte
daran wir fahren dann fort mit dem
premierminister
großbritanniens